And the bam taken twice a day like the other powder drinks to add it to the drink mixes
or just once.
So the bam for those who don't know what that is, which is most people on here don't
know what it is.
It's a product that we've created that I named it bam as brain anti-inflammatory mix.
That's what I named it so, but in truth it's not just for the brain but actually I created
it with that in mind.
So there's a bunch of anti-inflammatory nutrients in bam and it's a powder just like our medicinal
mushroom mix, but it has different things in it.
So bam is anti-inflammatory for everything in your body, but I specifically created it
for the brain.
And should you take it twice a day with the other powders?
I would say yes, take it twice a day.
The truth is you can't really od bam at all and so taking it more often would be better
and you'd get more benefits from it.